Westworld season 3 episode 4 starts with
William he's mad with grief and guilt
because last season William killed his
daughter Emily because he thought she
was a host
he's also haunted by the suicide of his
wife Juliet he wakes up in a bath like
she died in a bath and he sees water
raining from a chandelier just like when
she died this chandelier has one red
sphere and five black ones just like
Dolores had one red pearl and five black
pearls including her own Williams
haunted by a vision of Emily who says
that William destroyed their family
including her uncle Logan and her
grandfather James jealous William didn't
directly kill these guys but his
domineering self-destructive hidden
nature did lead to his family's downfall
to its collapse like a dark star William
says he knows what's real and he's in
control but he doesn't want to take
responsibility for the terrible impact
he's had on people so it's a paradox
like the problem of evil either he is in
control and he's a terrible person or
he's not in control and he's a helpless
machine Emily shows him his profile from
last season the data from the forge
which records his crimes and shows the
code he follows like a host last season
Willy wanted to destroy the forge
daughter because he wanted to escape
this judgment and he wanted to prevent
himself from being made into an immortal
host in a loop like James Delos was so
in a sense William wanted to destroy
himself he shoots at mirrors which
represents self-destruction
he considers literal suicide because
it's the only way he feels that he can
prove that he has control but even that
is taken from him William gets a visit
from the host Charlotte she warns
William that serac is about to take over
the Della's company and wants to use the
forge daughter
so William agrees to help Charlotte but
it's all a trick Charlotte saves William
just like Dolores shaved William in
season 1 it's a symbol of control
letting someone put a knife to you
throat shows that you know that they
would never dare to hurt you but really
Charlotte is in control here than is
manipulating William because Charlotte
is not really Charlotte it's revealed
that this Charlotte and this Martin and
this musashi are all copies of Dolores
these pearls Dolores brought from West
world aren't the minds of other hosts
they're just copies of Dolores his mind
put into all these bodies and Charlotte
isn't really getting Williams help she's
actually having him committed to a
mental hospital as revenge for his years
of abuse of Dolores Charlotte also seems
to inject something into William or
maybe take a blood sample maybe it's to
track William or it's drugs to make him
crazy or something with William
committed Charlotte takes over his
shares in Delos so that should help
Dolores to take control of the company
back from serac so William ends up in
the mental hospital the man in black is
now all in white he's got a glove on his
right hand because last season it was
injured while fighting Dolores William
is now trapped much like James Delos was
trapped the exact situation he hoped to
avoid a vision of Dolores says that
William is a prisoner of his own sins
Williams only problem this whole story
has been his own paranoia obsession and
self-destruction so the only way he can
have freedom is to change to find his
humanity face his trauma be a
half-decent person that was the idea of
the door quest last season Ford told him
to make it out of the park Emily told
him to come home to his family but
William failed and continues to fail
trapped in a prison of his own sins he
doesn't even know if he's real last
season we saw a flash-forward to the far
future where a host copy of William is
stuck in a loop a fidelity test to see
if William can ever escape his cycle of
violence maybe all of these scenes are
just part of that loop and Williams
already been replaced with a host
maybe his punishment is to never know if
he's real
so can William ever change
nature and escape or is this endless
infinite prison the end to Williams
story we see Bernard in a simulation
being created by Dolores it's not clear
if this happened in the cradle in West's
world or at Arnold's house in the real
world or if this even could be the
original Bernard being made years ago
but the point is that Bernard and Arnold
are important to Dolores he's a father
figure who believed that the hosts could
grow into real people and that's part of
why Dolores remade Bernard even though
she knows that he'll try and stop her
Bernard has a flashback of Arnold's son
Charlie which reminds us that this
Bernard is part Arnold
Bernard and stubs were both created in
Westworld now they get to hang out in
the real world for the first time so
naturally they sink some beers in
Southern California and everything looks
pretty familiar except now in the future
they've got reusable landing Rockets
like SpaceX Stubbs mentions he has a
shoulder injury because the actor Luke
Hemsworth hurt his arm which forced a
rewrite of the fight scene in Episode
two
Bernard thinks that Dolores has killed
Liam Dempsey and replaced him with a
host and he wants to stop her so Bernard
makes a little clicker button that can
freeze hosts like what's Iraqis to
freeze Maeve the robot lads dress up and
prepare to play a new role Dolores and
Caleb go shopping there's some
technology that digitally shows what
clothes look like on you this kinda
stuff has been developed in the real
world
Caleb feels uncomfortable buying fancy
clothes because he's a working-class guy
this isn't his style but Laura says that
style is just a marker of class and
tribe like animals with plumage just
like hosts humans dress up to play roles
and once you see that you can break free
of your role and you can use that code
to manipulate others Dolores wants a
Liam Dempsey's money so she gets the
Martin host to get Liam's financial
authorization key Liam is one of the
richest tech Bros in the world but he
lets Martin handle all of his financial
and security stuff so that he can spend
his time partying it seems like freedom
but really Martin's in
trol so this rich man is no more free
than a host Delores also steals the
blood of Liam's money guy Michael
so that Caleb can use the security
markers in his blood to impersonate
Michael caleb is nervous his palms are
sweaty but he successfully plays the
role of a rich [ __ ] and steals all of
Liam's money showing that status and
class are just as artificial and coded
as the roles that hosts follow Maeve
chats with serac in a fancy singapore
bar and Ciroc explains why he wants to
control the world
when Ciroc was a kid he saw Paris
destroyed a Westworld trailer mentions a
thermonuclear incident in Paris in 2025
so it must be that serac and his brother
look weirdly similar to young Ford and
his brother who we saw as hosts is it
possible that Zurich and Ford were
brothers or do all children look like
that in 2025 frolicking in fields in
formal dress
either way the point is that young
Zurich witnessed a terrible preventable
tragedy so he wants to control
everything to prevent disasters from
happening again to stop humanity from
destroying itself it's a pretty good
reason to want to rule the world but it
also raises questions about freedom
should we let ourselves be controlled to
save lives serac controls the world with
data technology on their computer raha
Guam and the insight company but his
data is not yet complete he wants West
world's data from the forge because the
forge data is the most complete map of
the human mind in season one the whole
idea of the West world Park is that it
gives people the freedom to reveal their
true selves like William outside the
park acts like a family man and a good
guy but inside the park he reveals his
true dark self that's why the West world
data would be valuable to serac data on
the real true identities and choices of
the human mind would allow him to better
control people like Caleb and everyone
else in the world
apparently the key to unlock this data
is in Dolores Sousa Rock once may have
to go capture Dolores for him although
we do now know that there are
at least for Dolores's is the key in all
of them or just one or split between
them or what but in return Sirach says
that he'll upload Maeve into the sublime
the digital paradise for hosts so that
she can be with her daughter in robot
heaven forever we were told that the
sublime was sealed away and inaccessible
but serac claims that he can get Maeve
in any way and if she doesn't comply
with him he says he'll trap her in a
digital hell forever so serac plays the
role of a devil tempting Maeve into
conflict promising paradise that maybe
he can't be trusted and his promises are
empty Soraka takes Maeve to Arnold's
house and says this is where the
divergence started which threatens sir
axe plans all these circular images this
season seem to be from the computer
Rehoboam identifying people who are
going against sir axe plan he thinks
Dolores is the big threat to his plans
but Bernard also came from here so maybe
he's the big threat to serac we see that
Dolores printed 5 host bodies here she
made herself a Dolores body and Bernard
and Martin Loras and Musashi loris and
she printed the new Charlotte unless she
just reused the old Charlotte body that
she came in in which case there could be
a mysterious unknown fifth host for
Dolores 5th pearl out there somewhere
serac has this guy Jang an identity
broker who helps Dolores set up a fake
identity as Lara serac interrogate sang
and shows him images of his family
suffering but serac says that he's not
gonna hurt Jiang's family this isn't a
threat it's a true simulation of what
the world would do to Jiang's family
if Zurich fails and Dolores wins which
suggests that the world really would be
better off under surak's control but
then serac murders Jiang so he's still a
villainous character he kills people in
his quest to save people Maeve follows
Jang's information to a woman called the
mortician who provided blood for Dolores
is fake identity the mortician treats
human bodies like objects to be chopped
apart and sold just like how host bodies
are treated in West world Maeve hacks
the more
device two stopper calling for help may
have learned some super late hacker man
skills in Westworld
the mortician refers mave to the Yakuza
so may finds their base at it i doand
distillery it i Doan is a Buddhist
concept about unity literally meaning
many bodies with one mind so this refers
to how Dolores has copied her one mind
into many bodies the Yakuza have
cyberpunk guns that aim automatically so
it may fax them so the Yakuza role shoot
each other
Maeve learns of the Yakuza's new leader
called sato is actually the host Musashi
who may have met in Shogun world last
season Musashi complains that may have
left him to die in the park
Maeve says it was musashi's choice to
stay but Musashi says the choice wasn't
real because Musashi didn't know that he
was a robot in a theme park this is
similar to how William says that his
choice to kill Emily wasn't a real
choice because he didn't know that Emily
was human and this Musashi isn't really
Musashi
he and Miss Martin and his Charlotte are
all copies of Dolores because the only
person Dolores trusts as an ally is
herself
it seems that Dolores isn't taking over
the world for all hosts she's just
filling it with copies of herself like
agent smith in the matrix she's
spreading and replicating like a virus
the Yakuza base is full of white goo
which is used to make hosts so maybe
Dolores is making a heap of bodies to
copy herself into an army of herself to
fill the world but she also talks about
building a world for Mapes daughter so
maybe she'll take the real world for
herself and build a virtual world for
all the other hosts and leave no world
at all for Humanity Musashi kills Maeve
and she bleeds out into the white host
goo which is just like this host
bleeding into milk in season one milk is
connected to motherhood birth creation
and growth while blood is connected to
death the season 1 intro had this milky
white stuff and season threes intro has
this red stuff playing with these
concepts of birth and death and if you
mix these two together you'd probably
get something like Caleb's straw
berry milkshake Musashi goes to take
Maeve's pearl so that Soraka can't keep
using Maeve but then he just leaves it
behind because they run out of time or
because Maeve is being tracked or
something it's really weird to not take
this pearl maybe Musashi Loras believes
that even if Maeve is fighting against
them she still has a role to play
just like Bernard Liam and Roderick and
Penny go to a fancy sex party for rich
people like in Eyes Wide Shut while a
classical rendition of wicked games by
the weekend plays high-class sex workers
are displayed on pedestals and auctioned
off a cache Broderick says that all sex
is commerce which is like what Maeve
says in season one in her brothel Liam
and Rodricks dynamic is much like
William and Logan in the park so the
point is that in both West world and the
real world people are objectified sex is
a commodity and the world is a
playground to gratify the rich Delores
says that the real world is no different
to West world Roderick gives Liam a
fancy new drug called genre that sends
you straight to the silent era the next
West world episode is called genre and
Liam still has that drug so maybe next
episode will be a drug trip to the
silent era like that one episode of
Watchmen where a drug trip takes a
character to the black and white era you
might want to watch our watchmen videos
they're pretty good burnout crashes the
party and tries to freeze Liam with his
button but it doesn't work because Liam
still a human not replaced with a host
if Dolores wanted to replace Liam with a
host she probably could have done it
when he was alone with Martin earlier
she must want Liam alive as a human for
some reason Dolores intercepts and
fights with Stubbs which is sad because
Stubbs doesn't want to fight he's just
been programmed to by Bernard it's three
seasons in and hosts are still being
forced to fight each other for coded
conflicts penny and Roderick are
surprised to see Dolores kung-fu
fighting robots at a sex party because
they thought she was dead Dolores taps
the side of her head because she once
said to Roderick that that's the nucleus
accumbens which evolved to make humans
believe in God now Dolores is like God
undying homely present
unstoppable Dolores once said that the
real gods are coming sir Roderick best
start believing Martin captures Bernard
and Dolores captures Liam and as all the
storylines sync up it's simultaneously
revealed that Charlotte and Martin and
Musashi are all copies of Dolores the
reason why this is interesting is that
as we learned last episode these copies
aren't identical clones they're more
like two lorises children who grow and
change and make their own decisions so
they might not all follow Dolores as
plans
this episode is called the mother of
exiles which refers to a poem on the
statue of Libby it frames the statue as
a symbol of hope a powerful maternal
figure who'll welcome and protect the
downtrodden so is Dolores this mother of
exiles will she protect the downtrodden
like Caleb and her host children or is
she just taking the world for herself
his mave the savior at least four hosts
like her daughter or might Bernard be
the real hope a more compassionate
compromising person who doesn't [ __ ]
murder people all the time will serac
save humanity despite his brutality or
will one of the Dolores copies find new
possibilities or RD&D the Savior's we
need after all west world presents lots
of different perspectives on freedom
hope and control so it i Doan is a
Buddhist concept Buddhism has been
practiced for thousands of years and a
lot of it is about how to deal with
suffering so in stressful uncertain
times Buddhist texts can be really
helpful regardless of whether you
consider yourself religious or spiritual
if you've never read any Buddhist stuff
you might like to start with the
Dhammapada it's simple and short and
wise and an absolute banger and you can
get it on audiobook for free right now
by signing up for trial with audible
members get an audiobook each month and
if you cancel you keep the audiobooks
you can listen while you drink in
Singapore or while you wait in isolation
sign up at audible.com slash ASX thank
you for watching please like and
subscribe
we're holding live streams right
after each episode of Westworld season 3
at 10:30 p.m. Eastern Time Sunday's
patreon supporters can watch live
streams after their broadcast thanks to
patrons Alistair Twombly Kelly Quinlan
Madeleine Welsh Amy Moffat as Naevia
Jonathan Bell and Geng Chen and drom
Cheers
you